introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
pilot program that will be run at MIT
University in Kolkata the program is
going to be dedicated to the
introduction of bioinformatics and we
will talk about the applications of data
science and biology biotechnology and
healthcare the program will take place
at Amity University Kolkata and will run
for three months
this will include 11 workshops that will
be followed by a team project the
program will be run by experienced
bioinformaticians that have experienced
both in academia and in industry
dr. Burton Chakraborty holds a PhD in
bioinformatics and dr. Mohit Mazumdar
holds a PhD in computational biology and
machine learning together they will be
working with faculty and students at MIT
University helping understand various
types of bioinformatics including
processing of next-generation sequencing
data application of various analysis
tools including machine learning tools
and interpretation this project will
this program will be followed by a
project where each faculty member and a
group of students will be able to
prepare and submit a poster or a
finished analysis of a project that they
have selected we will start off by
introducing the omelets logic ecosystem
the Onyx logic program includes an
overview the Onyx logic program includes
various tools and resources that are
provided in the scope of this pilot that
includes online courses
projects and datasets that will be able
that there are already uploaded on the T
bio info analytical platform will also
talk about the expectations and schedule
of the training program including
important deadlines
one of the big topics we will talk about
is the impact of big data and
bioinformatics how knowledge driven
versus data-driven discovery and various
examples could be explored in
agriculture neuroscience cancer biology
immunology including defense and
healthcare applications well we'll talk
about Big Data and bioinformatics the
topics that we will cover include
knowledge driven versus data-driven
discovery examples and various
applications and biotechnology
neuroscience agriculture cancer biology
immunology and various industries like
defense and act and healthcare and we'll
talk about the emergence of
high-throughput experiments in life
sciences how the central dogma of
molecular biology that DNA code
transcription of the genes and
translation into proteins can be
measured in a qualitative and
quantitative way we'll talk about next
generation sequencing how we can use
that sequencing how we can use this
technology to detect DNA variance and
measure RNA expression then we will
transition to transcriptomics a section
dedicated to gene and Aiza form
expression in the context of this
section we will talk about the role of
pre-processing various mapping
techniques and quantification of genes
and isoforms in a sample we will then
talk about analysis of variance how we
can tell how we can use filtering noise
reduction in normalization techniques to
explore large multi-dimensional datasets
more accurately and summarize what we
have found using analysis of variance
how we can look at outliers and various
techniques so that we can detect groups
and trends in the data in
transcriptomics 3 we will talk about
more in-depth gene expression analysis
using correlation clustering and other
data mining techniques we will take a
look at analysis of genes and samples
based on those genes
then we will talk a little bit more
about metagenomics the microbiome is a
hot topic and we will talk about the
reason and the significance of
metagenomics including how next
generation sequencing of 16s hyper
variable region helps us understand the
composition of the microbiome and the
taxonomy of bacteria found in a specific
sample we'll also talk about the
significance of the gut microbiota for
human health in metagenomics 1 we will
discuss the various research areas and
topics and metagenomics how to
practically build a metagenomics
analysis pipeline and various methods
that are used for interpretation
visualization and analysis of results in
the introduction to machine learning
section we will talk about various
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning methods we will talk about
regression factors and features and we
will talk about various challenges
associated with different types of
methods in machine learning 1 we will
learn a we will learn about decision
trees discriminant analysis and support
vector machines we will use feature
selection and then talk about how do we
expand the number of features that we
want to include in our analysis we will
then talk about dimensionality reduction
and various data visualization
techniques finally we will come to a
stage where we were transitioned from
the theoretical learning to the
practical application of acquired skills
to an independent project here we will
talk about identification of correct
datasets for a bioinformatics project
various inputs and outputs and how can
that help us plan the team project as we
embark on this analysis journey
so a significant time will be allocated
for team projects and throughout we will
meet and discuss the selection and
preparing the various project components
we will hold Q&A sessions with students
and faculty and then transition to
poster preparation guide lines the
hands-on sessions will be conducted
online and offline and will be led by
doctor per team Chakraborty and Mohit
Mazumdar throughout the program each
student will have access to our online
learning platform that contains courses
project examples and also helps monitor
progression so that each person can look
at their progress the various courses
that they have completed and the points
that they have accumulated in the
process of doing various tasks
associated with these courses even
though the topics we've covered might
cite might sound technical and
complicated you do not need to worry we
have a full interactive online platform
that anyone with even the most basic
computer skills can use that means that
complex bioinformatics methods running
computationally intensive pipelines and
visualization of results can all be done
in a simple point-and-click interface
for those that have followed the program
and have completed the necessary
materials a certificate of participation
will be offered
we hope that you will join us for this
exciting course in introduction to
bioinformatics we are excited to work
with image University Kolkata to
introduce bioinformatics to a wide range
of students and faculty and see how
together we can develop impactful
projects that will help understand the
applications of bioinformatics to
various domains including healthcare
biotechnology biochemistry and their
applications in agriculture neuroscience
oncology and immunology